hello everyone and welcome to another title
tuesday i do love a good title tuesday who doesn't
and um we're going to be watching the creme
de la creme fight it out in this fantastic
online competition the best i reckon online
competition that is held on a regular basis i
mean you sometimes get 900 titled players playing
and this week well let's go and have a look shall
we who's going to be playing in a quick second
the game did you start in under two minutes now
so looking at the list have a look at some
of those names leading the charge at the top
is hikaru who's that guy anyone anyone know
who he is what's what's he good yeah yeah he's
pretty handy isn't he very very strong and
he's won this competition more than anyone
else but he didn't do so well last week he
lost a couple of games and he withdrew early
and we can go down the list very briefly we
have the big fish now the big fish is this
incredibly strong player from russia who knocked
out the well who's been a player who's been said
tipped to be one of the next world champion and
that is ali raza and that was a brilliant result
by federsev and then we have mvl who's leading
the candidates along with nepo possibly could be
playing magnus carlsen for the world championship
match in niche geary we'll we all love a bit of
a niche gear don't we uh very funny chap and the
list goes on let's just see well one player that
springs to my eyes here is daniel naradicki
now daniel is someone i've commentated with
before and he seems like a really nice guy and
i'm really looking forward to seeing him play uh
so i want to actually have a look at some of
his games today um i'll be keeping an eye on the
twitch.tv chat so hello to everyone in the
twitch.tv chat how you all doing hello hello chess
pastor uk hello to mineir hello to uh everyone
else you know who you are you're all in there
so good to see you there um and it's gonna be
a fun couple of hours so it is basically um
11 rounds of three minute chests plus two seconds
of move and they are off well let's start with
hikaru and hikaru with the black pieces here
playing against a russian feed a master and
he's playing the king's indian defense now just
to just to give you a tip where my head moves
if it goes that way twitch chat if it goes
that way i'm in trouble because that's where
i'm looking for my commands from chess.com if it
goes this way i'm actually looking at the chess
i don't know if you wanted to know that or not but
you do now anyway so um right so hikaru is playing
a favorite kind of setup of bobby fischer's
actually here bobby fisher in one of his well
his most famous book my 60 memorable games played
this setup that hikaru is playing but with the
white pieces and he's turned it around reversed it
and i really like black setup in these positions
because the thing is black is attacking white's
king and white is attacking on the queen side
now what's more important the king or a little
pawn over the queen side like if white breaks
through he might win that pawn there oh
brilliant fantastic if black breaks through
he's gonna win the king there and he might even
be ready to sacrifice on h3 as we speak but first
of all he's holding off white's counterplay so
this again if you want to learn this opening have
a look at some of bobby fisher's games he played
this incredibly well you have ideas again you've
always got to watch out for the sacrifice this
is something that is is a little bit worrying for
white you know you take here you bring the bishop
down the king is not very well defended black can
also try to bring his bishop to some more active
square i suppose if white doesn't get checkmated
white is doing okay but he's got to avoid getting
checkmated and hikaru is quite good at check
mating he's only spent 12 seconds getting to this
position um so well yeah i mean again hello to
chess vibes i hope that's peter good uh good to
see you in in the chat peter and um i mean bobby
loved the king's indian defense um the opening
that he car is playing i'm really happy to see top
players playing the kings in defense because it's
an opening i love a lot as well it's so exciting
uh but what's happening here well can hikaru go
knight takes e3 i think that was quite a basic
tactic that white just fell into there
let's just have a look at that again um
we had this normal position where white is
absolutely fine if i was white here i'd probably
try to go knight b3 i want to get the queens off
the board because when your king is under danger
get the queens off but he played knight d5 which
is quite poor calculation and after knight takes
knight the bishop has to be exchanged but then
hikaru has this move which is called an intermezzo
rather than taking that back which might also
be okay he can go knight takes e3 threatening
the queen and after some more moves we get to the
current position but hikaru is simply a pawn up
and look at this really weak pawn there on e3 this
is already losing for white i find this um quite
quite weird it's quite psychological people
don't really talk about the psychological
side of chess enough but when you're playing
a legend like hikaru you kind of overthink
things you should play more naturally and here
i think white just thought oh i'm playing hikaru
and he probably didn't play as well as he normally
would and rook d1 now played what's the the
bar here the evaluation bar has gone a little
bit crazy well totally crazy why is it he's got
look at that plus seven so i wonder what the win
was there was there a forced win bishop takes h3
why didn't hikaru play bishop takes h3 oh look at
that just call me the new hikaru who needs hikari
when you've got the ginger beard why didn't hikaru
play that the simple point being if you take the
bishop back check and that's what i call a juicy
check so that's that's a little bit strange from
hikaru maybe not a good sign of course he's
still doing very well here in the position
he's a pawn up but he could have come he could
have won another pawn very easily there so that's
a little bit a little bit peculiar but i
think we're going to move on i think it's
pretty clear that hikaru will win
this game now i did mention daniel
naradicki and well let's go over to his game he's
actually playing another grand master from india
and i'm not going to click on the name but you
guys if you want to check who their real handle
is do log in to chess.com well there you go ah
i just saw a very cute picture of daniel ah it's
a picture of him when he's about three years old
holding a chess trophy obviously an early starter
and here white resigned because black is crashing
through on f2 queen takes f2 is coming and well
it's pretty hard to stop that one um right so we
will now go and jump into another game and we're
gonna have a look at mvl and this position looks
much more even nvl playing m is that is that from
egypt so there's not many egyptian chess
players and in this position well you would
say that black is better because black has this
very active bishop and good rook when you're
trying to assess the position you should look
at two things the pawn structure and the pieces
and you know even if it takes you a lot of time
it's a great way to improve look at who's got the
better pawn structure here white might have the
better pawn structure because this pawn on d6 is
very weak if you've got a bad pawn structure you
better make sure that your pieces are very active
to compensate for that and in actual fact
having peace activity and better pieces
is often more important than having a good pawn
structure because good pieces mean good tactics
and tactics win the game and in this position well
all the black's pieces to me look very scary maybe
the knight will now come to d4 this is the kind
of thing that's possible put the knight on this
square here okay mvl is coming in with the idea of
checking and winning the bishop and obviously time
is a very big consideration here so the white king
trying to run away but now the knight does come in
and this should now surely be all over with black
winning a piece um g5 here very sensible move
black is a piece up and this is going to be the
end of the game the black king can march in as
well but mvl has other ways of doing it very nice
tactic night e3 is coming these these top players
they see tactics immediately immediately um hello
codders hope you're doing all right you're going
to make a book on this title tuesday i'm very
interested to know who you think's going to win it
obviously if we're talking about who is favorite
and you can keep an eye on the live scores below
i'm only going to be looking at the top 10
boards um you can go again into the chess.com
playing arena to look at more boards but if
you have a look at the top 10 players i mean
hikaru is always favorite because he's won it more
than anyone um now who else do i think some of the
young indian players have done incredibly well
in this tournament so arjun could be a dangerous
bet but he's never won it so let's move down and
we will go a little bit more now drop stone who
is a young russian player and help me out with
his name there in the chat i'm sure some of you
watched my show last week um is he he came first
equal i think last week is that right so he's he's
he's going to be one to look out for eric hanson
we all love eric hansen because he was brilliant
he was one of the original twitch streamers so
we got a lot to thank for the chess bras and
the energy that he brought to streaming and
uh yeah that's right so um just to remind
you who dropstone is it's david paravan who i can
never pronounce as the end of his name correctly
but david paravan and someone needs to say it
to me so i can say it properly being dyslexic
but you get the idea david paravan won its
last week so dropstone did win it last week
um and if we have a look at some other players
well this is mama jaroff who had a very bad loss
in the last round last week but good player we
all know who anish is i love to see niche do well
he's never won it in niche unless i'm wrong so
maybe it's his time you got champ here champ 2005
another young indian dangerous and strong
player i don't know who's going to win it
who is going to win it who's going to win it okay
come on guys i want to hear your suggestions while
okay we're just uh we'll see that there's oh look
at that checkmate can we just have a look at this
checkmate okay so hang on a minute look at this
position here this position okay this is a very
exciting end to the game so white is coming down
the board this way and black oh hang on let me get
this right no black is coming this way and white
is coming this way they both queen at the same
time so you would have thought draw right it's
a draw because they both got queens on the board
the time limit is three minutes oh let me
get this right it is plus two seconds no
one second to move i always get that wrong
so you shouldn't get flagged because you get
a little bit of increment and now black plays a
lovely little finish can you guys see the finish
can you guys see the finish here can you work it
out black to play and checkmate that'll give me a
chance to have a little swig of my tea even money
on hikaru hikaru really you're going to go even
money on hikaru i i would actually have a little
a little i no offense to hikar maybe that's a you
you are the odd maker uh and when we're talking
about we're just talking about in friendly ways
how we think people would do well uh giri or
dania i would go on dania i would go on daniel
um okay so the finish is queen to e7 check and of
course there's no point to only seeing the first
move and this is really nice this is actually
like a textbook finish where does the king go
now if the king goes to this square what is
the winning move here what is the winning move
let's oh round two starting the winning move is
this subtle little move with checkmate coming in
and after the king comes here check and mate okay
we better get on to round two though let's go
round two caught there quick here today right now
i'm going to go with daniel naray dixie because
let's go pick up from the first moves and
he's playing farhad rahman of bangladesh an
international master who has a decent rating so
daniel starts with e4 the rule lopez or spanish
if you can't pronounce the rule lopez maybe i
should just call it the spanish main line bishop
e7 and now well this is um one of the least sharp
lines this is a safer line um the main line is
where white basically plays rookie one and tries
to avoid moving with d3 the reason that white
doesn't play d3 is because white wants to play
d4 so the main line is something like rookie one
castles and now c3 because if white can go d4
and get another pawn to d4 that's really handy
two pawns in the center but then black has some
martial moves and it gets very complex so the way
that daniel played this he's playing it a bit
more slower and he's stopping the dangerous
gambit lines and he plays here a3 very important
when you're playing this opening to keep hold of
your light square bishop and the rule is as soon
as black plays d6 he guards this pawn so black
has a positional fret and the positional threat
is knight a5 winning that bishop or not winning
but getting rid of it and you don't want to lose
this bishop as white because it's a really good
attacker that's why you play a3 because now if the
bishop is attacked it has a little home to go to
um of course you're getting a master class on
the opening here i bet you didn't want that but
you're getting one anyway tough luck at castles
knight bd2 simple stuff h3 and now rook e1 this
knight is getting ready to travel to g3 d4 bishop
g5 and now we have this as the current position
uh this is the current position um as we are
and of course someone brings me on the phone
typical uh luckily i turned off the noise so if
you hear a vibrating noise it is just my phone so
in this position uh here well this is a standard
idea dating back oh actually maybe maybe okay no
i was just checking it it wasn't gary kasparov for
someone in this position this is a standard idea
where the knight well it dominates this bishop
and the threat was to win that bishop when you
can see the power of the bishop on b3 and this is
another normal idea you could take with the e pawn
or with the g pawn if you take the g pawn you aim
to check mate on g7 if you take with the e pawn
you're playing much more positional where white
now has this lovely square for the knight look at
that square and you can just see how powerful this
bishop is that's why you want to keep that bishop
this is really a masterclass in how to play the
rule lopez from daniel i mean look at that i love
i love that bishop so strong and i think daniel
has a couple of ways now to go he can go h4 and g5
h4 and g5 is a is one way hence why
black has aimed to try and stop that idea
and now maybe just bishop a2 okay daniel has
swapped that one off he goes rookie four and
i'm sure he's gonna get ready to play g5 at some
moment because the point is if he can open up the
h file all he needs to do is get a heavy piece a
rook or a queen on the h file and it's checkmate
so here we come real textbook stuff real real
so i i am in love chess patsy yuko i'm in love
i'm in love with daniel's play in this opening
whoa it's good stuff right now i am hearing that
um levy is is winning against anish geary i
don't know if that's true um let's just see
if that's going on are they i don't know if
they are they playing is this levy no that is
that is a lie okay thank you for making me go oh
no it's true it is going on okay let's have a look
at that because i know a lot of you are big fans
of both of these players uh it looks like daniel
narutsky was winning so we just have a look at
this game two of the most popular youtubers and
um well streamers around who've done great things
for chess gotham chess and anish and i have to say
looking at this position it looks pretty
terrible for uh for black this looks not just
pretty terrible it looks horrible um it's for
white i got i got it mixed up there for white
black has two bishops for the rook which is which
is pretty strong and black has these pawns in
the center of the board just about to come on
down the you know this is completely crushing
knight here threatening the rook maybe this bishop
can come round to c5 another thing you should look
for when you're playing you've got to look for
you've got to look for maybe this one is good
you've got to look for targets in your opponent
position there was an old book on attacking chess
which called these targets focal points you can
call them whatever you want they don't need to
have a pacific name but the point is you've got
to find a square in your opponent's position
like f2 which you think okay that's a target
and then you just got to bring your pieces in
to target that square as the bishop comes in
here i won't swap around games in the future
i don't like jumping games uh generally so i
am a bit sorry for going from daniel narrow
dixie's game but this is obviously a big big
game and now the two bishops are dominating
there's no threat on the seventh rank because
the bishop on f6 is so strong and we're just
gonna see oh oh oh oh oh what happened he just
blundered a whole piece a niche went mental
he blundered a whole piece i mean well not a niche
yeah niche black what happened he wanted a little
that was that that went what happened there um
well i mean let's just have a look at that he won
on time oh there i was i mean this position
easily winning easily winning for a niche
all he needs to do is not blunder any pieces
can we call him blunder a niche from now on
and he just has to go d3 d2 d1 queen thank
you very much it's not that hard push the pawn
go here i mean you can just support it with your
bishops but instead he played this howler this
howler bishop c2 ah i think everyone should go
into his stream now and tight bishop c2 bishop
c2 bishop c2 a niche weak bishop c2 go on go
and do it i'll have a little drink while you
go do that that's all you need to do is go over
there right weak bishop c2 don't actually do that
it might game of trouble we'll do if you want
to do if you want to be would be quite funny
i mean bishop c2 and now rook takes c2 and
all of a sudden here after this rook a2 i'm
not sure i like that one if i was white i would
have gone rook c7 because the point is if a5 we
can win another piece and you never know the way
anish was dropping them he might drop another one
um but in the end it was decided on the clock
with a niche playing very quickly levy did
have one second increment per move
but the final position to be fair
is not so clear i think a niche is absolutely
fine because he's secured both his pawns
and this pawn could become really dangerous and
niche is certainly not worse in this position
certainly not worse i'm having a look at the
chat okay remember if i look left i'm in trouble
yeah if i look left that's where i'm in
trouble don't make don't make everyone
leave the stream to go to anisha's no they
wouldn't say that nothing nothing bad going on
um okay any more games let's have a look do keep
an eye on the scores now another player a couple
of players who are um maybe not so well known
but always do well in this event is jos pem who
is an incredibly talented player from peru um
he obviously doesn't get the chances that a lot
of european players play he doesn't play many
competitions but he always does well in this
chopper chopper mate choppa i remember it as an
australian guy called chopper i watched the film
about some crazy australian lunatic anyone watch
that one choppa choppa that's my australian accent
pretty pretty shambolic right i don't hate any
kangaroos around give us a foster's um yeah i'll
probably get kicked out of australia for talking
like that um oh and we got the big p daddy the big
p daddy isn't number two peter svidler and does
he need an introduction there's some people who
just don't need an introduction he's one of them
i'll give him one anyway now is he how many times
has peter svidler won the russian championships
come on without googling no googling don't google
how many times has he won the russian
championships come on guys tell me who's gonna how
i mean anyone who's won the russian championships
as many times as peter swidder is a legend the
russian championships the hardest championships
to win probably because they're russian
um i think it's eight times i think it's eight
times uh a hundred maybe a little bit optimistic
he's gotta live to a very nice age to get
that one but he's won it so many times he's
a fantastic player round three cool you don't get
much of a break do ya okay now let's go to he car
shall we let's go to hikaru now um hikaru
let's go for the opening moves has played
g6 okay so the modern opening now
hikaru does play quite risky openings
and the perk is a risky opening this is a i'd
say not his first challenge but a grand master
2700 they're pretty handy i'm i'm one of them on
chess.com but i'm actually a bit lower than that
and now i always think f4 is the best move
here just in case you're wondering about
it this is the most testing get free pawns
coming at you bishop e3 is actually called
the 180 attack and the reason for that is on
the english chess circuit this is what i heard
is that many english players just went queen
d2 and when black castle kingside bishop h6 h4
h5 took on g6 swapped the bishops off brought the
queen to h6 and chet mated on h7 and they were all
graded about 180 or was it 160 attack i don't know
one of those two um okay so let's go on and we now
have a more positional approach and i think this
is the wrong way to play you know you're playing
hikaru who's a great player take him on take
him on start throwing your h pawn up him start
throwing your f pawn at him don't mess around with
positional ideas because the longer the game goes
on um i would say the better that hikaru chances
are and now he plays this very interesting move b5
this shows his tactical vision he's trying to take
the knight away from c3 okay someone's now telling
me it's the 150 attack so i said the 180 then
i went to 160 and now i've got to go 150 okay
um there we go and now g5 again i don't like
this move either i mean the idea of this
is to win a pawn but is it overextending let's
have a look so now white gets very greedy
and white has won that pawn okay
well you know he at least white
is taking the game to hikaru so let's
give i will give him some credit and
this position whites are pawn up but there's
something about black white's position over
on the king's side which i don't like too much
there seems to be a lot of holes over here and
you know a bit of pressure in the center i mean i
guess white's doing well but this is interesting
so okay we'll keep an eye on it we keep an eye
on this one i'm heard i'm hearing that anish
is not streaming is that the case he's not
streaming he's trying to win it okay well anish's
odds have dropped then if he's not streaming
or improved i think is what i meant to say
uh now it's two pawns up so why is white winning
i mean if white doesn't do something really stupid
white's doing well because what how did he win
another pawn okay now let's have a look look okay
this looks really bad for for black because
where's black's counter play so white has
defended this well he's defending that one he's
stopping the knight coming in here by defending
that and he's now playing a very sensible move get
the queens off the board if you swap the queens
off the board you take out a lot of
tactical chances and he's got this big pawn
push push it baby um h4 was that really necessary
he could have gone before and got his rook behind
the pawn let's just have a look at that i mean one
thing you get when you know you've got a winning
position you get scared just throw the pawn up
the board if you have a past pawn there's no point
just hello mate that you've got you've got to
lob it you've got to throw it and this would have
been much better because a rook behind the past
pawn is very strong because it supports the pawn
coming up the board but if we go back to the
game he's allowed hikaru to get a hold on that
pawn and he's still trying to swap off maybe
this is a bit too much swapping but he's gone
bishop g4 and okay it's still good for white but
i would have preferred for white to get that pawn
motoring up now who what do we reckon is is hikaru
still going to win this one i mean it's possible
it's very possible but white is playing very
well still this knight has potential to come
in and the black king is now the new target so
white can he bring he can go here and come into
f6 but he's trying to swap off more pieces
i kind of like the way white's doing this i
wouldn't play like this because i think white's
saying okay look um i oh it's mate it's mate
it's mate surely no knight f5 knight f5 is
mate and now this checkmate boom and quickly
oh i don't i don't really want to watch shikara's
face now but that was a real result for emperor 87
a real upset there congratulations it's not
easy beating hikaru so well done to emperor
87 and the books are going crazy the books are
going crazy hikaru has lost the game he's not the
favorite any more i mean he's got to win all of
the remaining games i'd imagine there's 11 rounds
there's no um like knockout at the end it's just
called a swiss system whoever has the best score
after 11 rounds and if there's two people on the
same score they do it on tie break which is this
number next to the score and the higher your
tie break uh the more chance you have which i
very nicely cut off there so i might i might just
try to readjust that in a second um twelve to one
now hikaru okay well let's let's have a look any
other games going on let me just uh bring them up
12 to one i'd probably have a little i'd
probably have a little bet on 12 to one but
it does depend it does depend if
um hikaru you know uh goes on tilt
hikaru seems to be uh quite an emotional player
and he's a really good player he's the best blitz
player in the field but when he's rolling he can
just roll over the whole field but sometimes when
he you know loses a game he goes a little bit
on tilt so you know he can upset him a lot and
i'm very similar to that myself meaning that
you know i i often like you know i i've lost
that game i get really annoyed with myself uh
really annoyed unfortunately codders i i don't
i don't have a chance to really whatsapp while i'm
doing this there's too many things going on maybe
another day when they got another commentator
i'll get involved but not this time so anyway
back to this game and this is the second seed big
fish oh it's great to see shiroff in second place
as i've mentioned in previous weeks shiroff is
one of my favorite players and okay uh russian
technique there and you can see that black's king
is getting forced all the way back uh shear off
one of my favorite players he's been a legend of
mine for a long time and as in you know he's uh
he he's he's he's just been up there fighting in a
really tactical manner he is mr fire on the board
uh so um yeah it's great it's great um okay so
a lot of names i don't recognize here i'm just
gonna see if there's any more games going on
they're probably all finishing now and let's
just see if we can quickly update this so we can
see oh a niche is at the top okay i feel like it
might be a niche's time to to to do something
in this event mvl lost we're being told as well
to an fm well you know fm's can be incredibly
good at blitz it's it's is possible um who else
don't i really know now i'm just i'm going
through these names there's a lot of players
um so a lot of upsets there's a lot of upsets
and let's say shear off i love to see alexei
with it he'd be my i like to see him win it more
than anyone else an old legend um alexander fear
is a very aggressive and entertaining player um
and we're hearing rumors i don't know if there's
just rumors in the chat someone's saying hikaru
working on a ban uh for for the guy really uh
i don't know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna speculate
too much but um i always love it when you know uh
someone loses and they're like oh ban him he
must be cheating um renuk how is i don't know
is it roonac roonak i'm gonna say is is playing
this time is he playing let's have a look i don't
know i'm going to see he's a young player from
india who does excel in this tournament a really
good blitz player eric hanson on three out of
three as well um and i'm just going to keep
going down daniel naradicki on three out of three
good stuff we have a look at his game jabarva we
haven't mentioned the ever interesting
and dynamic jabarva so that's also good
uh he's up there with three out of three who's
this guy vidit anyone know who he is vivit of
course a legendary legendary player i'd love
to see him play gyri they often stream together
um and let's keep going down creek is one of the
may the main streamer for brazil um really nice
guy chilled out chilled out giza and we keep going
down lawrence trent whoa okay i'm gonna have to
look at lawrence trent's game i'm gonna have to
i'm sorry i know you might be saying not trent
not that trendy we're gonna have to look if i can
find his name laurence is a good mate of mine and
um okay while i try to find his game i'll put
you on this one anisha's game and the niche is
playing black against branded jacobson uh where is
where is uh maybe now lawrence has pulled out the
tournament because he knows he's pushed you know
he's going to pull out the tournament say well i
was winning it i was winning the tournament my
internet went down i was leading what odds are
we getting on lawrence trent what odds are we
getting on lawrence trent that's that's what
i want to know he's so far down the list oh he's
playing sheer off ah we've got to look at this ah
okay sorry i'm getting excited so this is laurence
trent who you must have heard of and he's playing
the legendary shear off and it goes with d4 and
laurence trent has got his perfect opening in
can he take down shear off c5 now c5 in my
opinion is not a particularly brilliant move
because of lawrence's next move e4 and the point
of this move e4 is that after black takes you go
d5 and this is where pattern recognition is
very important i'm going to twist the boards
for one second to show you what my point is my
point is lawrence trent is especially a speciality
player in what we call the albion counter gambit
which is this move here with e5 and after taking
lawrence plays d4 now the way he's got this with
white he's got an extra tempo in the position so
if we switch the board back and i've probably
messed up everything now i'm very good at that
and we just reload the point now lawrence
has got his dream position but he's got an
extra developed piece so let's keep going he now
develops very normally queen e2 now i did analyze
this line quite a lot and it's very dangerous
for black because this pawn is a real thorn
but after knight takes e5 i think i came to the
conclusion that black should play very calmly
and just take this one but shear off goes for
queen a5 trying to start a counter attack king b1
and now bishop f5 lining up these bishops
so this is really really interesting stuff
now um this position i mean the albion i mean
obviously computers don't like pawn sacrifices
they don't pay much attention to the evaluation
bar but one thing we can say is that this position
is extremely interesting and shiroff now lining
his queen up now this is lawrence moving that
attacked bishop back and there is a threat here
of g4 trapping the bishop on f5 what odds are we
going to get on this game anyone want to speculate
on this game here what is going to happen on
this game um i'm going to say this could be an
upset i'm going to go for an alexei shearer wins
an upset according to lawrence it would be uh no
i don't know i'm gonna go um i i don't know it's
gonna be i i could see trent winning this one
trent can sometimes do it this is a crafty move
because it stops this one but now what lawrence
is going to try and do is play g4 but alexei
is bringing more pieces directly in towards
the king so it's a really exciting position
if alexei can get rid of this knight then
his bishop will be threatening to take on c3
so this is typical shirov shirov attacking with
everything okay so now lawrence changing his mind
probably and he's just trying to swap off that
attacking piece it does seem to me i have to oh
i don't like that move because of d6 but
then alexa is going to play knight d5
so he's done this one to get a hold on this
square so his knight can come here but now
what is happening what is happening this is
getting crazy knight takes d5 knight takes
as shiroff is sacrificing has he got knight to c
free check has he got this move if pawn takes here
oh okay so let's have a look at that so my point
is if you take the bishop can alexa play boom and
you have to take this one and then alexa goes this
is why i'm called mr far on the board checkmate is
coming you're just the trent i'm the sheriff
put that in your pipe and smoke it young boy
so here lawrence gets rid of that knight
he now takes on f5 and after queen g2
black gets his rook into a very dangerous position
knight f3 and here rook to e8 and i have to say
looking at the position i think i think we could
have an upset the queen is coming in the bishop
is coming in trent is on fire lawrence is on fire
is he going to do this queen takes d5 check look
at this attacking position this must be good this
must be winning for lawrence queen and knight are
very very good attacking pieces i knew this would
be a good game these two players very exciting
someone's saying jameson trenty sipping a glass
of wine i expect he's sipping a bottle of wine
oh come on cheer off give me that red wine
and then he goes check mate sheer off here
we go thank you for the game i am the trent okay
so bishop it must be quite off-putting playing
uh against lawrence because uh um you know you
uh he he's he's very dangerous and he's very
well known but he hasn't won the position yet
now what he's done is quite a clever maneuver
because i think he wants to position his bishop
here so if the rook comes down can he do that
well let's have a look rook here look at the time
as well i'm not going to move pieces on the board
because the situation on the clock will lawrence
choke this is the question choking means will he
actually win this or will he be like no and will
he choke will he will he choke will he throw it
away now after queen takes black's only hope is
to go queen e1 and take on c1 so queenie one must
be played or queen h1 one of these moves but 16
seconds left and the problem here oh he's not done
it he's not done it lawrence should be winning can
he hold it together they're both under 20 seconds
and shear off is former top three in the world and
he's still a very aggressive player lawrence is
at the moment completely winning completely
winning he can check and win this pawn somehow
queen e4 queen e4 get the queens off lawrence
queen e4 get those queens off but he's trying
to come round with some checks so he
can take that pawn very sensible play
um well that's what i thought he was doing i'm not
sure what he's trying to do now what's he doing
why is he going backwards and forwards
lawrence go queen b8 take the b pawn come
on laurence just take those pawns okay he's
found the move he's got to win this one he's
he's a hundred million pawns up now he's gonna
what's he trying to do now don't get too greedy
okay what's he doing he's
gonna be careful perpetual oh
dear um okay um so this must be winning but he's
making a pig's ear of it because the problem is
queen e1 was checkmate so he now has stopped that
one so let's just show that i i didn't actually
see that myself so in this position actually
let's keep with the game sorry i don't want to
move away from the game he's won he's won well
done lawrence absolutely brilliant and i just
want to show the end of that game one part this is
actually a trick that i might have fallen in for
um in this position if you ever play queen take
c4 look at that evaluation bar that was that was
a pretty shocking topple um queenie one checkmate
but lawrence has won very well done lawrence very
well done it might have been bad technique but
it got there in the end now we are going to take
a short break uh i now i believe that was round
four lawrence on four out of four congratulations
and i would like to thank a youtube uh
user um as well and that youtube user is um
is it fabian four seven one one who gave
a little donation so thank you there
and i'm gonna take a little a little break
well done to lawrence that is uh a brilliant
victory over one of the best players in the world
and well actually before i do take a break it does
seem that anish is still playing okay i say that
and who won and niche lost a niche lost to brandon
jacobson so niche has lost so daniel naradicki
how is he getting on daniel is on maximum as well
okay so we'll be back in no time at all we're only
gonna be back we're only gonna take a short break
time to restock or restock on your tea
coffee whiskey or wine or whatever you drink
and uh i'll be back uh yeah with more of the
action remember it's 11 rounds we've only had four
rounds there's a load to go a load of excitement
can laurence trent pull off can he pull off
i was going to say so rude there can you
pull off the most amazing upset victory
entitled tuesday that has ever occurred
in the history of mankind be back soon
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time this is the
magnus carlson squeeze um wow hicaro's
playing in front of hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now i mean
up by four games well i can resign yeah carl
knows it it started with 16 players and uh
it all came down to one man magnus carlson
this is a pretty great matchup i know people
love hikaru nakamura hikaru is the favorite
for a reason he's the beast an absolute monster
it has been hecaro's speech his championship
this 2018 in kara nakamura the overall one
c takes it home in the species championship
obviously this is a rematch of last year's scc
final what a finish by the way i mean that's been
the story of the match the kara nakamura has
just kind of out swindled out tricked and out
calculated wesley in the critical moment dude
that's a nice move wesley's shaking his head
i call her winston he's going to draw
this game i can't believe it which
happened unbelievable okay carlo nakamura holding
that position he had no business drawing that game
okay so it's been a very exciting uh i feel uh
first four rounds i mean this has been great and
you know it's always nice to see uh a friend do
well you're gonna be biased aren't you if you see
a good a good mate uh taking out a big name and
the big news so far if you've only just joined
in joined the stream why have you done that you're
in trouble is that lawrence trent took down alexei
shirov which is a fantastic result for lawrence so
well done now one thing a lot of people joke about
lawrence you know i've seen him on streams and
they joke about his strength now i do want to say
he's a really good player he could be a grand
master he's just shown that in that game he's
got a lot of potential i think the only reason
people joke about him it's normally magnus carlsen
joking about him and magnus carlsen get away
of joking about anyone's strength because he's
different gravy so well done um and having a look
at the scores let's have a look at the top and see
what is going on at the top there sorry i
had it on dim screen so you can have a look
a number of people on four out of four and we have
um becca 95 now i don't know the real name of that
now you can go and check out their their actual
handles if you want to go into the chess.com
live chess and just follow the title tuesday event
alongside this is anyone watching this on the
tv by the way i've just worked out how to watch
twitch broadcasting tv when i can sit back on the
sofa you know and just be like oh yeah it's a bit
of danny wrench hello danny you know just put my
feet up on the big screen it's very very relaxing
i don't know or where are you watching i'm kind of
interested anyway let's go through the list so
we have arjun who is this amazingly talented uh
player junior from india who's this guy who's
this guy eric hanson oh yes i've heard of him
from poland don't know this guy so well um and
going down the list we want to have a look blitz
streamers up there another famous famous streamer
who's on maximum points that's really good to
see and um there's a lot of people on four so i'm
just going to keep going down and this is dimitri
adriaking i think lawrence trent as we know again
federsev who's the second seed on maximum as
well um brandon jacobson who beat geary geary
blundering a lot today maybe he's drunk no i i
don't mean that of course maybe just having a bad
day daniel naradicki on four points as well so
there are 26 people still on maximum points and
we're in now um let me just update the games
update please i might have to do a little refresh
who should we look at who should we look at let's
do a little refresh and i'm going to go i mean i'm
tempted to go laurence trent but that might annoy
a lot of you so we're going to go and have a look
at eric hanson instead let's have a look at eric
so eric has the white pieces he's on maximum he's
playing lag manta from russia and it has started
with a caracan and he plays this system which
is quite popular and now after this move knight
to f6 is now the trendy move to play this is like
the trendy variation and now eric plays a really
safe move he plays d3 and he basically says i want
to take you into an ending this is this is really
strange i was assumed eric was a very aggressive
attacking player but he's allowing the end game
to occur here so he's now playing a bit like off
anderson or some in-game legend and it goes on i
might not be looking at this game too much because
it's not the most exciting but we will get up to
date with the position and here well i think the
strategy has worked out very well because there's
a big tactical threat or bishop takes b7 this idea
of putting the bishop on b7 is not a good idea
you need the bishop to defend the knight
there you need the bishop to defend the knight
and the problem here is what does black play
if black castles queen side eric wins a pawn
if black plays king e7 which would be natural to
try getting a rook in you still take the pawn and
you're going to go rook takes d7 next so instead
oh my words oh my words i thought this was going
to be a long end game grind instead black
found another way now what's what you want
if you're in life if you have to blunder either a
pawn or a piece stick with a pawn that's my wise
words of the day if you've got a choice a pawn
or a piece do the piece he castles boom and now
rook takes d7 oh dear right i hear the crowd is
going crazy for a bit of trent action and is he
doing it again he's doing it again laurence can
we all here at lawrence can we all hear a trent
in the chat come on i'm gonna do it trinity
come on come on trendy trunty okay there we go
and i think he's got a good position here again
right i mean he's got two pieces for the rook
and look at his pieces they're coming in this must
be good for lawrence he's playing a grand master
from russia a young grandmaster from russia
and hello to um ruland in the chat as well
and now he's just keeping it very simple now
the rule is really if you have two pieces
for the rook that is a very good thing the two
pieces work much better than one rook on its own
unless you get really deep into the ending if
you get into a late ending the rook comes to life
but there was a big threat of knight takes there
now can he do something with knight here this must
be good for trent if he just or maybe knight f4
knight f4 just try and take this one with knight
f4 the knight can come into e2 this is really good
for lawrence are you gonna get to five out of five
get what's he done why is he so good what is that
oh come on lauren oh i see i was about to blunder
a piece with this one when that was the move but
here you can even go king e8 here because if rook
takes here knight e2 check would a one but he's
maybe getting a little bit nervous this is kind
of the move which shows a little bit of nerves but
he's still doing well he's still doing well the
king goes back here and we have more moves i'm
hoping that it's going to automatically update
and now more pieces getting swapped off i don't
know if this is the right strategy from lawrence
i don't think you should be swapping off
pieces because like i mentioned before
the king and rook are actually very good in
the ending i don't like the way lawrence is
doing this i'm not sure about this anymore i know
that he's got a big advantage he's got to get this
knight in the game where is that knight going is
he going to go g5 and bring it here it's not clear
i would yeah this is better let's try to get the
knight somewhere good but where e5 that's where
you want to get the knight to so how do you get
the knight to e5 maybe king here and knight d7
this would be a good idea get the knight to this
square so in order to get it there you need to
get it to d7 in order to get it to d7 you need
to move your king out the way so i like king v8
knight d7 knight e5 he's gone this way where's
that knight going the one thing with knights
you've got to find the best route for them and if
anyone's improving their position it's now white
white is coming in with the king i don't come on
laurence you're you're you're i don't like this
okay now he's trying to trap that rook he still
probably is better but look what white's doing
whites look at the knight why is he put the
knight there when you're trying to find root for
your knight make sure you okay you can go no he's
gone back he should have gone to a8 then b6 and
then here and then here where's that night going i
don't think morris has a clue what he's doing here
lawrence come on man you've gotta you gotta
you've gotta get get a grip on this um
did it drop a pawn was i dropping a pawn with
king d8 i didn't see that okay maybe i was i mean
so his new idea is to get the knight to f6
um but i mean of course white shouldn't win
this one because white can't do anything hang on a
minute hang on a minute it's nearly checkmate here
oh okay what was the move there there was a big
swing he could have played knight takes h5 oh no
lawrence and this would have gone knight
g3 and if rook takes you go g6 check
so lawrence misses a chance and instead
he goes back to doing some slow maneuvers
bishop f6 g4 and he's got to find a way to break
through and he's now bringing the king back
i'm i'm a little bit worried that lawrence really
has no idea what he's doing am i allowed to say
that lawrence i can and here now the king can
come back again king f7 and lawrence has got
to try and make pro i don't see how he's making
progress i don't see how he's going to do it the
only thing he could try is get his knight to this
square this is what i've tried so knight d7 is he
going to finally try this one no he's coming back
he's gaining a little bit of time on the clock
he's going back again this is going to be
a perpetual this is going to be a perpetual
and now i just don't see how he's going to
do this he hasn't found the right plan here
he's going backwards and forward um knight h7
can you try that one where's the knight going
no he's going for the draw no lawrence and maybe
white is even going to try to win by playing g5 i
think lawrence has said i can't win this i'm going
to take the draw and this must be a draw knight d7
you've got to play this move he's played it good
boy good boy because at least now he can put the
knight on this square and that is some kind of
progress i think because now the rook is passive
and you've got to try now no don't move the knight
away don't move the night away get your king to g5
i mean it might be a draw it might be a draw
um the position anyway but i mean in a real
game you'd think oh rookie six could have been
quite strong there no um there's still a lot
going on this could still change anyone think
he's going to lose anyone think he's going to
lose anyone i think lauren is going to lose this
he has actually kind of thrown this away right
uh but now white is looking a bit dangerous
white's getting the rook in here oh no don't lose
this one don't lose this one lawrence please don't
oh no he's getting very short of time oh no oh no
lawrence no lawrence what are you doing man what
are you doing oh this is painful come on push the
h pawn and pray push the h pawn and pray why is
it oh i don't know if i can watch much more of
this to be honest this is getting a little bit too
painful it's like you know it's like oh dear it's
like watching someone with a terminal disease
in hospital isn't it this it's like you know
you know you like the guy and it's just oh no
oh no lawrence oh no what have you done what
have you done man oh no oh dear this is this is
just not good and the d pawn is now queening and
um oh no i it's a pity laurence is
not streaming this as that would be
very funny but this is this is just getting more
painful get ready for the funeral get ready for
the funeral it's not going to be pleasant and
you can see in disgust he's playing on but
uh i don't know why i'm even looking at this
game it's kind of one of those morbid things
where you just have to watch it until the end you
know and oh no oh no that was an absolute travesty
i have to say he played so well he played so well
laurence and he ended up losing oh laurence oh
lawrence oh laurence that was actually i think
um primo man defined that well it was just a car
crash that was a car crash to watch wasn't it he
was doing so well no anyway maybe he'll come back
but we're we're still going to keep an eye on the
five out of fives and we saw there's still a great
tournament ahead even though we got no laurence at
the top now can't always get what you want we have
these guys on maximum so let's just have a look at
the scores and we have angry twin i'm not going to
click on all their names you can have do that
yourself at home matty bar is um oh i know this
guy he's a really nice guy but i my memory rubbish
strong polish grandmaster eric hansen alexandre
moscalenko who's i believe the guy is he the guy
who's written some really good books on chess no
no maybe maybe i'm not sure might be he's a
good player pavel penco another strong russian
a lot of russians up there today right on maxman
um bartel bartel that's right bartel really really
nice guy strong player um tinderman i don't know
who this is daniel narutsky okay i'm going back
for uh me personally i'm gonna support daniel
naradicki um and you can see there's some famous
names just below and four and a half ariane
terry is on four and a half champ um don't
know who that is former prodigy we're just going
to go down see that group blitzstream doing very
well well done blitzstream and jabarva jabarva who
might be streaming himself so do go and check out
uh his stream as well occasionally don't
leave me now you know but you can check out
the stream and the next game started so i think
we're going to look at daniel naradicki now
because he's one of my tips before the
tournament and i'm going to blast through
the opening moves very quickly again i didn't
realize the game started now i can't believe
timmerman has played the orangutan now there
is a rule any opening that is named after an
animal is bad so just bear that in mind and
daniel naradicki is going for quick developments
now white has the better pawn structure because
he has more pawns in the center of the board
but black has very good developments black
now trying to push forwards in the center
and we can see that daniel has created some
problems by pushing forwards with this pawn
they're moving really quickly so let me just get
up to date with the current moves and white very
cramped in this position and we go into an ending
and this ending is where we stand and it might not
be so bad for white but again the pawn structure
is even evaluate pawn structure pieces but the
pieces are quite bad for white because the knight
on the rim is dim night on the edge of the board
the bishop is also very passive and daniel already
has his rooks on very good squares he now brings
in his knight to create some problems maybe even
coming into d2 the other idea is just to take
the bishop gain the bishop pair so bishop here
played trying to pin that knight down and that
looks like a good move maybe white can try some
rook here but now daniel just supports his knight
so it's definitely better for daniel in this
position has daniel ever won has daniel ever won
title tuesday before let's get some
updates come on guys has he ever won it
quite possibly who knows and remember the live
scores it's 11 rounds if you just come and join
us it's 11 rounds and this is one of the premium
chess events online it is the title tuesday event
it happens every tuesday you have to be a title
to a title tuesday you have to be a title player
if you want to play meaning you've got to
be a grand master feed a master beth harmon
or someone like that and these are the top 10
players so it's not open to anyone only open to
elite every tuesday chess.com we're halfway
through on round six of 11 rounds and it's
blitz chess so it's three minutes per game plus
one second to move so you get an extra second
every time you make a move which is kind of
kind of makes it a little bit easier right
um now daniel going for g5 and you can see black
gaining space over here with what is a porn storm
porn storm it's raining pawns hallelujah at least
i didn't say porn that would be weird when if i
said that um rook c3 now daniel using his pieces
he's threatening to win the night on a3 so i
imagine okay well white's decided to take that one
off and get his knight to a good square but there
is a phrase about the two bishops and in this
position the two bishops are looking very strong
look at that poor bishop there that poor bishop
is caged in is caged in by the pawn on f4 it's
basically trapped this bishop is just like
it's been entombed it can't get out of its tomb
totally entombed with these guys goodbye
bishop it's just like a piece of wood
it's not doing anything it's been suffocated so
black i'm expecting will win this one keep an
eye on the clock they're both under a minute now
um and here well another thing black is trying
to do is get his rooks to this rank um it was
an old book by nimzovich who was a great player
hundreds of years ago maybe a hundred i don't
know precisely he wrote a book called my system
which was revolutionary at the time
and that book gave oh i love that move
just trapping the rook in and one of the
things he said was if you can get your rooks
on your opponent's seventh rank then that is
going to cause them a lot of grief he probably
didn't say in those words but you get the idea
this rook is pressurizing but there's a lot
of tactics going on here white now threatening
the rook here but black ready to take that one
um what um okay hello to blair as well barbary
mccack in the chat hope you're doing all right um
and um you can by the way codders you can trust
blair barbary mccack he's a good friend of mine
and vice versa so i would actually bet on narrow
daniel narra dixie to take this one to take this
title tuesday i'm just putting a little bit of
pressure on him he's doing very well in this
game he's going to win this game no doubt about it
now what's he going to play here can he even play
some move white is threatening to take the
bishop but can he allow that to happen and
then bring his rook into the position
here where he's pressurizing the bishop
on g1 so daniel using a bit of his time
they're both now down to 20 seconds
and instead he just keeps it simple and he's
going to try and pick up that pawn on a4
just to remind everyone uh bullet chess is
not the time limit here bullet chest is where
you have one minute each for the whole game it's
basically who's got the quickest wrists you know
i won't do the quick wrist action and daniel
naradicki is one of the best bullet players
in the world so he doesn't mind about
the time and now he has the extra rook
white is suffering if only daniel can get his rook
around to the h file that could be the end but the
other way to win this is just to pressurize this
square here so you can try to attack that one the
king a very good piece in the ending so also
this is just completely winning now for daniel
he's bringing his king up the board combining
it with pressure against this and it's going
to be what we call zugswang well okay it
wasn't this is going to be completely winning
bishop goes to c6 i expect no he's going for mate
instead rook h1 next move well done daniel so that
puts him to six out of six and i'm just gonna see
if any more of the leaders are playing and it does
look like we might have one more game and that was
a draw so is that maybe there's only two players
on maximum points out of about 700 who started
well done to daniel who won that one daniel the
game we're just looking at is in second place we
have an international master in first place which
is quite rare to see because the highest you can
get in chess is grand master so when they have the
i am next to their name that's only international
master only it's very hard to get there but it's
not as good as the gm score so free players it
looks like eric hanson whoa great to see eric
doing very well if you want to check out another
great stream uh well a great stream then go and
check out the chess bras eric hanson streaming on
that channel as well and maybe he's streaming his
games he normally likes a bit of techno music
in the background to to get the juices going
that's my techno dance or chicken
head as it can also be cool
um now who else is on five and a half let's
just have a quick look at the score there
so we do have jabarva who is this maverick
chess player who comes up with crazy ideas
in the opening and he really shows a
bit of his personality there jabarva
kind of reminds me like of ex-world champion macau
tau and macau tau does remind me of beth harmon in
some way because beth harmon was rather excessive
of course i'm talking about the queen's gambit
and um world champion mikhail tao was
very excessive he had a um a pensions for
uh alcohol and other things but he was one of
the most brilliantly talented attacking players
and there's some great stories about jabarva um
shall we just stay staying up very late at night
um and turning up the board the next day in like
the european championships and then crushing
his opponent in 10 moves or so and so lots of
legendary players but we only have three players
on six i'm hoping eric is going to play
daniel naradicki um i don't know who cuban is
so maybe someone can find out who
the cuban is now i'm keeping an eye
on the twitch chat as well so hello to everyone
in the twitch chat good to see you there
um pip and chuck ginger gm how do you think you'd
do if you were to play entitled tuesday i win it
easily clearly i just i just like giving the other
players a chance now and again you know i can't
win it every week can i you know just go give him
a little bit of a chance i don't know i i have
played in it a lot you can check out my youtube
channel uh ginger gm on youtube and i've got
lots of videos there of me playing title tuesday
and commentating um i've never won it i'm i'm i
i think the best i've come is maybe top 20 out of
6 700 players uh i'm too slow i'm too old and slow
now you know it's a young man's game yeah i'm
40 years old i might as well put my slippers on
get my pipe out that sounds wrong and my hot
chocolate and sit on the porch and just chill
that's where i see myself okay the next round
started so i have missed okay let's just get an
update who is playing it is okay daniel naradicki
is playing the other leaders so i'm gonna get up
to date these are two leaders playing and now
daniel's just played b3 one of the things i
really like about daniel's play is he plays every
opening and he's now transferred this opening
as we're going to see into the birds opening the
birds opening is named after english player henry
bird who was a very strong chess player some time
ago and it's like a reverse touch and as we go on
we can see that we're basically getting a
pretty standard position in the birds and now
one thing i love doing here is trying to bring
my rook around just to check mate so does he
go for this he does daniel does try to bring
his rook around but this is a very good break
from black this is black's main break to liberate
the rook and to liberate the bishop and queen you
can see before that this pawn was in the
way of that but now after some exchanges
black is going to liberate one of those and
blacks won a pawn because this pawn on e3
is said to be in a pin meaning it can't move
because you'd lose your queen it's pinned down
so daniel brings another piece over it's
not all bad news for daniel daniel has this
brilliant bishop looking at the black king and
a very dangerous knight around the black king
black swaps off that dangerous bishop and we're
going to get to the current position very soon
but now he's won the pawn back so he gets rid of
the bishop but he's lost the pawn i'm wondering
here if knight h6 was a possibility my idea
is knight h6 and if you take here i take on f6
and if you move your king well i'll just
take there anyway i love sacrificing
um but okay he didn't play that daniel went rook
to f3 instead b5 and now he's got knight takes g7
put that in your pipe young man and smoke it
and this has a similar idea this is a lovely
little tactic we're just trying to get rid of the
defense the pawn that was defending the knight on
f6 so we're demolishing the king side over there
and if you take the knight i will take that
one there and it's defended and i have double
power rooks on an open line are very good because
they function very nicely on the open file so now
black counters attack by threatening checkmate
the threat is queen takes their checkmate
you've always got to watch out for your opponent's
last move and see what they're doing and now he's
got knight takes e2 what is happening here he's
trying to keep this knight on pre knight takes e8
queen takes g3 knight f6 check king h8 i'm just
going to get up to date with the boss queen h5
threatening checkmate knight to f8 defending
checkmate queen takes peace and now daniel
seems to me to have won a piece at the end of
all that violence core dear oh and there's a
big blunder at the end there this is kind of what
we call a sniper queen it's kind of hiding away
from everything you don't see it cause it's
on the other side of the board and you go
yep i'm coming down for you and then all of a
sudden the queen whoa jumps to life what happened
there what that that was over very quickly
brilliant play from daniel but i think i think
black must have been doing okay at some part but
the position really turned when daniel was allowed
to play knight takes g7 so the big mistake by
black was not looking at white's dangerous pieces
you've got to get into your opponent's mind and
seeing what his most active pieces are playing
probably black should play something like knight
g4 here threatening checkmate immediately because
the way he did play it with b5 allowed this move
and daniel was winning after that now let's go
to eric hanson's game so eric hanson can he keep
up the 100 score he's playing champ 2005 who is
champ 2005 anyone know by the way did you get a
bet on i wonder if there was a a little uh i'm
not saying a financial because obviously that's
not appropriate but blair did you get a bet on
i'd like to know now in this position who is
the champ who is who is this guy i'm not going
to click on the name here because it'll take me
away from the scores but someone could tell me
uh okay that it is renuk um sadwani okay he he's
changed his profile name right oh it's his other
account so renuk is a really good player i think
he came second two weeks ago and did he come third
last week so he's kind of due for a win and he's
he's really taking eric hanson to the cleaners
here these bishops look at them he's now won the
rook there and this one threatens both of them so
the bishop comes to defend it but this is this is
completely winning for white of course and eric
is not gonna be on the only person on
maximum is daniel it's daniel um so
and who did you who did you get a bet on uh by the
way uh blair i'm interested i'm interested to know
who who's your man we're keeping on the scores
here by the way i'd like to know what everyone
who everyone thinks is going to win uh the
tournament who i'm interested no okay so now
eric's getting a little bit back in the game but
he is a whole rook down and after rook well can
you take that one the only danger that white's
got is his king's a little bit exposed so black
can now try to come in with the check but can we
do a checkmate here okay this is a very safe move
get the queens off the board and eric can resign
here basically because he's just a whole rook down
king g3 rook h1 probably gonna be checkmate as
well because the black king is very very short so
well done to renuk who is he's only is he only
15 he's only 15 years of age i can't believe
how strong this guy this guy's got an abundance of
talent 15 15 years old unbelievable and he's now
gone to six and a half we only have one
leader daniel on um on seven oh you've got
any i am to win okay that's quite interesting
um that's a bit that's a that's a little bit uh
that i don't i'm not sure about that that that
bet blair you guys should always have a little
have a little private private one on the on the
games i think could be quite funny my money is
on the only leader daniel naradicki who does a lot
of commentary for chess.com so you may have seen
him commentate before so go and check him out
daniel naradikshi has his own twitch channel so
go and look at his twitch channel as well you can
check out my twitch channel um well ginger gm is
basically my name my twitter account is is ginger
underscore gm so if you want to see what i'm up to
ginger underscore gm ginger gm youtube you'll find
me if you want to stalk me you can you know you
wouldn't be the first you know um this game is
all over the place what's happening here white
must be doing well okay now this is a winning
position i guess because of these two pawns but
hang in a minute he's blundered oh no it's check
blimey and yeah these two guys are running right
past pawns they're like running men they are
running up the board running up the board and
black's only chance is to get through to the
white kings this is a little bit of an upset
you can see the grades and black is the favorite
here but he's getting outplayed by white and he's
trying though to get some kind of draw has
he got a perpetual what i mean by perpetual
if you repeat the same position and he
has he's managed to draw unbelievable
they managed he managed to draw that one if you
repeat the same position three times in a game
of chess it can be a draw you can claim a draw um
okay so that's a very good save um by is it savion
uh savannah savannah that's how you say it
savannah young russian grand master um okay
now there be another break after the next
round after round eight just to update you
on the scores um was that a draw
in the end it was a draw okay
just to update you um on the scores at the moment
well you can see the list here it's seven rounds
of 11 have been played we're getting to the
crescendo of the tournament there's only
four rounds left and daniel naradicki the
popular streamer is on maximum these guys
biting at his heels oh we have the exotic princess
i'm not going to talk too much about that handle
um i've talked about it a lot it's probably
one of the worst handles you can have but
there we go he's one of the strongest players we
can get away of it eric hanson dropped a point but
he's still up there with a shout on six out of
seven i think the winning score could easily be
10 out of 11 it could easily be 10 out of 11.
so um that is that's worth bearing in mind and
so these people is is hikaru still in the mix i
don't think he is but we do have the likes of mvl
who is in the lead in the challenger to the
world championships over the board in real life
and he's got a good chance of even facing
magnus carson for the world championships
uh aneesh giri is up there i don't think he's
streaming today he's been blundering a lot and the
next round is off so i'm gonna now look
at jabbar's game it's always interesting
to see this maverick player how he's
getting on if i can find his game while
i mean the daniel naradicki game is a big game
as well let's stick with this one because this
is maybe a key game to decide the whole tournament
we have daniel naradicki and we go for the opening
moves he goes b free again and he's playing
this incredibly talented with 15 years
now the way the reasons oh why is that okay
sorry about that for some reason you had echo
there i think i pressed the wrong button
or something happened that was weird okay
no echo anymore it's always good
to have a little bit of echo
don't you want to hear me twice hear me three
times i could put you on put myself on three times
if you want the idea of white's opening here is
to prove that this bishop can be a very good piece
but by doing that white gives away a space
advantage and black gets a very big center
and having a space advantage is very useful in
chess and by that i mean black's pawns are further
advanced into white's territory white is a little
bit more cramped white hasn't advanced any pawns
past this rank on the other hand black is sort of
controlling uh all of this rank here now let me
just update has it really been frozen or is that
an error on my end let me just see if uh i'm going
to refresh the page quickly um which probably is
not going to help is it let's see if we can do
that again yeah i thought that okay we're going
to go back we'll just update the moves there
it did freeze a little bit but on the other hand
white has this brilliant bishop so it's it's kind
of a thing between those two things and now both
sides developing quite quickly and after castles
queen h4 black starts the first attack and black's
threat is to just crush on h2 here um bishop b5
check means that black can't castle and of course
you want to get your king safe when you're playing
but the king can now not castle because it's
probably gonna have to move um and this is a very
interesting position i i i don't know who i prefer
probably prefer white but when black does move the
king it kind of i don't know if renuk has some uh
problems with his connection is that possibility
hope it's not my connection because he's moving
very slowly at the moment okay he has moved and
i think you have to and now i'm wondering about
ge5 does black play this move because this pawn
is the one pawn blocking that bishop so you
want to get rid of that pawn and g5 is one
way to challenge the pawn on f4 if that pawn on f4
can be removed you have checkmate coming up on h2
uh i expect a4 will be played here oh no he's
got in here and he's threatening to take the e4
pawn i kind of like white's position because this
pawn is very weak black's king has not castled and
that means the rook is trapped on h8 that rook
on h8 cannot get in the game is trapped there
and this pawn here may just be lost um
oh no he didn't do that what did he do
okay so queen e7 can we just
go queen e2 queen c2 oh g4 wow
and now take this pawn daniel naradicki doing
very well i think if he wins this game as white
he's got a very very big chance to win
the whole whole thing he'll be on eight
out of eight and he is a pawn up now black's only
chance is to try to get at the white king i feel
because the white king you could say that the
pawns in front of it are the bodyguards and
here the bodyguards have gone a little bit further
away i don't think that's a major problem because
white is protecting himself very well there black
gets a threat he threatens that pawn so white
defends the threat white must be better but
actually now h5 very clever move black trying
to use the rook if he can open up the rook towards
h2 it would be well let's just say pretty juicy
and he's now put in this little move in the middle
where if you take that one it's checkmate anything
is possible now any result is possible i think
black has won a pawn back time situation they're
both getting to less than a minute and at least i
think for daniel he's managed to swap queens off
you have to say ramak came up with a brilliant
attack there from nowhere i think it's now
time to have a look at the pawn structure and the
pieces i still like white's position because this
night having a knight in the middle of the board
is really good it seems to dominate the bishop
this bishop is stuck on a very bad square you
can't get rid of this knight you could you have no
pawns with black to attack that night that night
will sit there forever just sit there and be like
i'm just gonna sit here i'm just gonna enjoy
myself in the middle of the board you can't get
rid of it and now daniel try this is getting worse
and worse for black this pawn here really weak
really weak porn and i think white's king is quite
safe the rook does a great job of defending it but
the main issue is just this pawn can white take
it straight away i probably wouldn't because my
night is so good you can take your time it's best
not to pick the grapes in early season wait until
they get a bit of maturity in them and then you'll
have a much nicer crop of wine when you pick them
don't get the immature grapes get the exotic
nice older grapes but he has eventually taken
that pawn and i'm not sure he should have done
that because black's got his rook down to be free
um and is runak in a bit of time trouble the
answer is yes i don't know what's happening here
what are we gonna predict i
mean it's it's a draw ah boom
i'd be a good chess spectator
wouldn't i i'll be sitting there draw
boo i wish you could do that at chess tournaments
you know live chess tournaments i mean it might
put off so many other players but any time a
draw is agreed you can go boom get out of here
you know like they do and execute execute them
we don't want to draw we don't want to draw um
i think i think i should have a button ready where
we have that and i can make some make some sort
of nice sounds going on okay but i mean at the end
of the day that's not a bad result and we have for
daniel because he keeps his lead but someone has
joined him it's the exotic princess strutting his
stuff at the top there which is going to lead
i mean jabalva and one more player alexander
catshow oh hang on a minute so blair's bet is
in blair had a cheeky bet that cacho was an im
was going to win the tournament you're back in it
blair you're back in it so we've got three players
at the moment on seven and a half and i mean
these two players i'm sure have won it before
has daniel naruto won title tuesday before i'm
still going for daniel naradichi but i really
am a great fan of jabarva i don't know
the guy the international master in first
um and it's tightening up the field there's three
games left i'm gonna take a another break now
there is a break after round eight i'm gonna
stop myself up on a bit of tea so cheers you
can get a little bit of tea in if you want to a
little bit of green tea i feel keep the energy up
and um i'll be back very shortly so i'll be back
in a couple of minutes don't go anywhere um we've
got loads more exciting action to come and go and
get yourself cup of tea and we're going to get
ready for the end of this fascinating tournament
three rounds to go who is going to win this week's
title tuesday can daniel narodicy keep his lead
over the other players see you soon back in a sec
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time this is the
magnus carlson squeeze um wow hicaro's
playing in front of hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now i mean
up by four games no i can resign yeah carl
knows that it started with 16 players and uh
it all came down to one man magnus carlson
and this is a pretty great matchup
i know people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
the beast an absolute monster it has been
hecaro's speech his championship this 2018 in
car nakamura the overall 1c takes it home in the
species championship obviously this is a rematch
of last year's scc final what a finish by the way
i mean that's been the story of the match the kara
nakamura has just kind of out swindled out tricked
and out calculated wesley in the critical moment
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking his head
ikaro wins the pawn he's going to draw this
game i can't believe it which that happened
unbelievable nakamura holding that position
he had no business throwing that game
well we're back again for the last segment of uh
this title tuesday event i'm actually just looking
uh this is really funny you're gonna find us very
amusing i've been looking just at the chat in
chess.com uh not on the twitch chat but actually
under the game and daniel naradicki is chatting uh
on on the thing and uh apparently i don't know
if we're going to get confirmation on this but
daniel naradicki is apparently on an airplane
and he's playing on his phone on an airplane is
that is that is that actually is that is that
true how can you get good internet connection
on your phone uh on the airplane i i i don't
understand that i don't understand that at all
so i'm just looking at the chat and he says give
me some slack i'm on an airplane i don't know
maybe it's a maybe it's a euphemism or something
i don't know interesting so um he's he's doing
pretty well for someone who's playing on his
phone on an airplane um and um yeah interesting
stuff and we also got some information that daniel
uh won the first ever title tuesday event so uh
he certainly won this event before um i you know
that was a while back obviously when was the first
title tuesday event i don't know when was it when
was the first title tuesday event anyone know that
um it keeps one one thing i don't know one thing
why twitch does this it keeps doing the echo
it keeps doing the echo is that right uh okay
but that should be all right now a little little
technical issues probably me clicking around too
much so anyway um the next game's gonna start
very soon we've got three games left let's
just have a look at the list of leaders very
very exciting um finisher that could happen
we've got these three alexander cacho
of russia i don't know who this guy is i don't
know is he another russian prodigy quite possibly
and then we have daniel narrative we talked a
lot about exotic princess leon beast is mvl from
france very very strong player champ is i'm
really impressed by this kid's play he's
15 years old i mean what was i doing when i was
15 i was being very naughty and not playing much
chess that's for sure um but yeah what a what a
potential champ he is he's got a good name there
um and angry twin is another international
master up there on seven this group on seven
points could also um win i think the winning
score this week i reckon it will be 10 out of 11
but i might be i might be wrong of course so
that means these guys have to get two and a
half out of three to win i reckon it either be
10 or it will be nine and a half that's my guess
vivit another strong player and let's just scroll
down a little bit we've got penguin penguin is
well he beat hikaru last week one of the fastest
players one of the fastest draws in the west he's
amazing amazing bullet player i saw penguin
once play i think it was blindfold 15 second
bullet so what that means is he had 15 seconds
not for one move but for the whole game he had
to play the whole game in 15 seconds and he was
blindfolded so he couldn't see what he was doing
so he could only see the i mean it just it's just
the discombobulator love that word i was like for
a bit of discombobulation in the nation oh yeah
hello to fiona in the chat as well i hope you're
doing well fiona go and check out fiona's twitch
channel which is fian shetter it's it's legendary
it's a legendary channel um could see so many of
you in the chat today anisha's kind of up there
but i don't think he's gonna win it on six and
a half i think seven points is really the group
hikaru is little he's biting on the heels there
he's on six and a half he's doing a little nibble
he's nibbling away he's saying i'm gonna win my
next free i might still get in the money honey
am i still getting the money we will see so the
games have started and we're gonna have a look now
at all this is a big game mvl versus jabarva
these are two brilliant players now mvl
with the white pieces really must win this one
to have a chance because he's half a point behind
but he has the advantage of the white
pieces the white pieces is kind of like
having the serve in tennis you
know you get to smack your opening
in your opponent's face take that take take
the spanish have a bit of english opening okay
and we have quite a solid approach from jabarva
here shabbath is known for his kind of obscure
and unique openings but here he's given mvl a
lot of respect that mvo is simply developing
maybe the bishop will come here or here the
early stages of the game control the center
get your pieces out and get your king castled now
the pawn structure i would always say that white
is a bit better here because white has an extra
pawn in the center of the board now that might not
might not look like much but having an extra
central pawn is quite a big thing it's quite
a big thing it can help you later on and a normal
approach here which grand master keith arcol uses
a lot is what's called the minority attack
and that is this is a more positional game
than some of the other ones we've seen and when
it's positional it means that both sides pieces
are not really as active you can see that
the bishops not really doing much they're
just waiting so more often than to do with how
you use your pawns and the minority attack is
when you attack your opponent's majority of
pawns with your minority so these two pawns
can aim to attack these pawns here oh look at
that a bit of green a bit green eh a bit of green
and um we might see that coming up later on
on the other hand um jabarva has decided to to
just pressurize d4 another approach i
might consider here is using the h-port
to try and why i love pushing harry the h-born
to try and to um attack the king there um
so um this okay but you can see
he's going for the minority appoint
his report is that film the minority report he's
doing a little minority attack and i think he's
gonna maybe play on both wings now oh no he's come
in the center interesting decision so he's opening
up the center of the board and i think that's
because his bishop was trapped and by clearing up
all the pawns in the center the bishop here might
come to life so he's trying to get this sniper
better range give it a better range um and now the
position is continuing with maybe pawn takes here
and something like rook d2 but the danger of
playing like this for um okay he's grabbed
the pawn but now black's gonna grab the central
pawn to me it looks very even this looks like a
very even game i don't think mvl should have
played that move that's a little bit rushed
sometimes when you're controlling the position
it's much better just to wait and try to build
it up little by little you can always press the
turbo charge button and if you're controlling
the position but pressing it too soon can lead
to lots of simplifications and the more pieces
that get swapped off when it's equal material the
more likely to a draw it's going to become and
this should be a draw but it doesn't mean it will
be a draw mvl now thinking how he can try and
cause some problems he's got to be a little bit
careful of his back rank um so he's played g3 so
that his king has another escape square on g2 but
this could be a mistake look at the bar the bar
has massively changed queen a1 queen a1 this seems
really strange he's gone here instead oh queen e4
check trying to fork the king and the rook so if
you take on b7 queen e4 and this is what's called
a fork attacking two pieces at once so after
queen e5 now mvl has to come back and defend
and black certainly has a better position now
for a start black can just win a pawn on a5
could jabarva win this game and that would be very
good we have penguin just looking at the scores
keep an eye on the scores below there's only two
rounds left after this one penguin is shot up
and this position now very tricky for mvl black
is a porn up so he blundered with this g3 move
g3 was too slow uh can chabada win this one
he's trying to get his king a little bit safer
and if i was black here i'd be trying to
maybe create a past pawn so mvl would stop that
one by controlling that instead chabad has got
another way he's trying to play this he's trying
to exchange queens off and go into a rook ending
one thing i know about mvl is that his rook
endings are brilliant mvl is such a good defender
when you're one of the best players in the
world you have to know defend and he's gone
for this one very interesting decision and if
pawn takes pawn black will beat two pawns up
but then white can get his rook behind the pawns
and when you're okay he's done this way he's going
sideways i thought he could have come um oh no
that didn't happen sorry getting excited there
okay he has he's got his rook behind the passport
this is end game technique and grand masters
generally always know where their
pieces should go in the ending
and this is why chabath has moved his rook back
getting your rook behind the passport is key
and he's not in a rush to take this one black's
winning plan is to come over with the king
and then support the pawn coming forward so
you've got to use the king and the pawn to
come forwards like this um very good winning
chances on the other hand mvl needs to try and
create some chances over there over there
he needs to bring his king in and try to
win one of these pawns at some point white's
going to have to give his rook up for the pawn
because otherwise you can't stop it these guys
literally just come forward like space invaders
with sound effects that took a lot of effort
but i don't know how he's going to do this
okay well he can go king b2 b3 i think
it's winning for black it must be
because there's no way that white can win
a pawn over here okay he's gone for it but
this pawn rook b7 is winning rook b7 is
the winning move at some point surely
get your rook behind the pass pawn that would be
winning if he plays that is winning he's done it
rook behind the past pawn jabarva is gonna
win brilliant result from jaba he's leading
and now this pawn is unstoppable i don't
think there's any way you can even give
your rook up for the pawn and of course
the black king now gonna take everything
only chance here is to play
rookie one this is the only chance
but this must be winning now because you can
get your rook your rook up you get your rook
behind the one pawn oh this is brilliant and
now we come up and come here still very close
but this is the winning way and there we go it's
checkmate next move very nice finish as well
and that does there's two players in the
lead and it's two of my favorite players
daniel naradinsky one again well done to daniel
apparently playing um maybe playing on an airplane
and we have jabarva jabhava generally streaming
as well so you can check out his stream
it's always good to spread the stream love i feel
vidit is up there this group on eight out of nine
very good chances but there's no real ims up there
the only i am is in sixth place he's gonna need to
get a couple of wins on the board there uh penguin
good to see him i don't know who two pack is
he's come back from that he's come back from
the dead two-pack what's my favorite two-pack
song i'm trying to think now what's my favorite
i can't remember any two-pack songs shame on me
and vidit so it's really exciting isn't
it really exciting i'm just to see if
there's any more games we can leave it on uh
while we have a look favorite two pack songs
calefanya okay you're not going to get me singing
now that would be really embarrassing yeah would
no no no no no no no no no i was tempted i need i
need i i'm on the tea today i certainly need wine
or something before you get me singing i mean i
don't know i don't know if chess.com be very happy
if i drunk a load of wine and then
commentated it would be very amusing
but i'd probably lose my job so um you'd
definitely get some singing out of me what'd
you guys reckon do you want windups no no
no no we're not going there i'm sticking
to the tea i'm sticking to the tea being very
well behaved um so at the top let's just have
a look um the penultimate round is getting
very close to starting we're in round 9 of 11
and there's only two more games to go the time
limit three minutes plus one second to move
and you don't get knocked out is your accumulated
score quite important and i haven't actually got
that very well shown i'm gonna just let me just
do one oh round ten started let's not worry about
that we're going straight this is the game this is
the game whoever wins this game will probably win
the whole competition and i have to say it's
a bit tough for jabbar who gets a second
black in a row jabarva is black again whoever
wins this game will win the whole competition
are they going to agree a quick draw and try
to win the next one jabarva's going for the
black lion come on black lion him and someone's
done a very good course on this and i really do
like this system for black it's very solid but
again most ground masters prefer white's position
because white has the space vantage meaning
he has two pawns in the center of the board
and black only has one but daniel now taking that
pawn off so we get a symmetrical pawn structure
meaning that there's no advantage in the pawn
so it's all coming down to pieces if the pawn
structure is reasonably symmetrical equal then
there's not going to be many weaknesses there
it's who's got the better pieces and it looks to
me that white has the better pieces this bishop
attacking f7 this bishop could be very useful for
attacking that square but it's not a big thing
black's pieces on the other hand
this bishop a little bit blocked
so a little bit but if i if i was white
here i'd bring my knight to f5 now
get the knight in get the knight nearer the
king this knight's not doing much will he
play it will he play knight h4 will he play i
like i'd love to see him play knight h4 here
is he going to play it is he going to play
if you're wondering where i'm streaming from
it is sea world is it sea world there is actually
a place oh he's gone the other way okay he's gone
the other way he's trying to bring his knight
out this way the one problem that black has here
is this bishop so this is the issue there's a
place actually off the south coast of england
or the east coast of england called seaworld
which is basically this place which has claimed
itself as its own country but it's actually
like a fort from the war i don't know why i'm
talking about this just in case you want to know
about sea land sea land that's the one sea land
and um yeah it's got a really interesting history
they basically claimed this fort um as their own
territory really weird but why am i talking
about c why why how did i get onto sea land
anyway back to the position it looks now that
white is really going for it whatever the result
of this game you've got to say to daniel who could
have taken maybe an easier approach and gone for a
draw you've got to say to daniel i like your style
because he's throwing all the pieces at black's
king and i like the way he's at least trying
to win rather than taking a draw he's going for
it and he's now maneuvering another piece over
to attack the black king funnily enough though
the computer really likes black's position but
jabbar decides to go into a little bit defensive
bringing the bishop back to defend these squares
daniel brings another piece into the attack even
though the computer likes black i have to say i
would take white here because i love attacking and
saying that jabarba's starting counter play in the
middle of the board he has the open file daniel
going forwards remember whoever wins whoever wins
this game is probably gonna win title tuesday the
prizes are four prizes it's a thousand dollars for
first prize not too shabby you might be able
to get a little piece of sea land with that
potentially um and the knight comes in so what
is okay well this could be a sacrifice because
now black is thinking black could play knight
takes d3 pawn takes bishop takes b3 winning a pawn
but now it's white's turns have some fun and
white has one two three four pieces attacking
and white could play something like knight takes
h6 and if you take that one back i come in here
showing the dangers of the position so back to the
game bishop takes f5 i think black had to get rid
of that dangerous knight and jabarva now aiming
to swap the queens off the board this is very
clever play from black white's queen is very
dangerous as we saw in that last position
so he's trying to get rid of the queens
and now he's centralized his queen
i have to admit now it's looking good for
jabbar he's picked up a pawn the exotic princess
is showing her charms knight takes e4 i think
daniel was in serious trouble here his attack
just didn't work black has defended brilliantly
here very nice defense from black bishop to e3
where's the queen gonna go it'll probably no it
can't go there because then the knights on pre
can it go to okay he has to keep an eye on the
knight this is the only thing because that you
can easily work out if a knight is okay or a piece
is okay and defended if you calculate how many
pieces defending that night this knight here and
the queen here so i've got two pieces defending
how many pieces are attacking that knight the
bishop here and the queen so there's two pieces
attacking in order to win a piece you have to have
more attacking than your opponent has defending so
um that didn't happen knight g4 daniel was playing
very risky jabarvas won the rook but daniel was
going all out for the attack all out for the
attack knight takes f6 can white check mate with
these three pieces somehow i don't think so you
can see just how strong this bishop is this bishop
defends the king side this is why black did that
very clever move and moving the bishop back here
um does white have any chances it's looking
really bad for daniel but keep an eye on the
clock funny things can happen when both
sides get short time which they are here
bishop c4 aiming to attack the pawn on f7 and
i think it's still looking good for black but
it's looking actually looking a little bit more
dangerous because there's a big threat if white
can take on h6 the black king becomes very exposed
so he's found a way to defend but now he's won a
pawn so this is actually a little bit unclear a
little bit unclear now bishop g5 bishop g5 can
you play bishop g5 this could be very good bishop
g5 rook takes f7 no could he have done this move
let's have a look bishop g5 and if rook takes f7
bishop takes the d8 but instead daniel has played
bishop f4 but look at the time queen d7 bishop g6
this is a critical moment in this week's titled
tuesday competition the black king is now looking
really exposed daniel is coming up with some great
attacking pieces and moves oh i don't know
maybe daniel is going to do it he's going to
do it i to be honest i think in this one it's
the typical case that chibava was doing well
but when you're playing blitz chess it's more
important maybe not to be doing well but to
have the initiative and now white is completely
winning he might okay bishop takes f5 look at this
rook daniel was winning queen g6 is a big threat
he's going to be going crazy jabarva is going to
be going crazy this is checkmate bishop takes
f6 is coming or queen h7 checkmate in one move
is check mate what a turnaround well
done to daniel unlucky to jabalva oh
what an end to the match that was that
was a brilliant end and you have to say
ja baba's chances have now been lost uh it's
afraid afraid afraid it's gone that bad way
and daniel naradicki turned up the heat there at
the end let's just have a look how it happened
around here jabarva has won a pawn but you know
what daniel says and this is a brilliant thing to
do we can all learn from this when something goes
wrong in your position and it's gone wrong for
white here because the black knight has won a pawn
there is something that's saying okay i'm just
going to go all in i'm going to take many more
risks now that the position has gone wrong and by
that you can just go oh you know to hell with it
have my rook have my rook i don't care and instead
i'm just going to go straight for your
king this is like the kamikaze approach
obviously the famous japanese pilots when they
were losing the war they're like okay well look
i'm just going to go for it i'm going to give
my life up to cause as much damage as i can
and you can see this kind of happening now
with the king and the problem is black is
doing well but the king is more it's more in
a precarious situation compared to white's
king which is very well defended here so and that
was the the telling thing and as the game goes on
you can see that white's bishop starts to create
real havoc here creeping in to the position
now if you want to avoid the ads you
can obviously subscribe to the channel
do remember if you do subscribe there's so much
stuff on chess.com that you can that's going on
and it's a good way to support uh presenters like
me and the people who make these shows possible so
you know it's an easy way just to just to get
good free content um okay so we're going on um i
think is it penguin you should be concentrating on
your games you know you're in second place penguin
you're playing for first so penguin is in the
chat and twitch which is quite amazing and look
he is now on nine points and he's playing against
daniel naradity this is gonna be one major game if
penguin wins he's gonna win the whole thing
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready oh yeah i hope he's not listening
to the commentary while he's playing to be
honest that would be a terrible idea if he was
listening to me suggesting moves on his own game
he wouldn't be at the top of this chart he would
be i think more down the bottom so yeah but it's
very interesting to see the scores who else is up
there hikaru has made a little comeback he's in
fifth place so hikaru's on a bit of a roll of wins
as well um and we just saw jabbar lose that one so
it's the last round let's go and we're this is the
game for the whole championships is all on this
one penguin needs to win if penguin wins you've
got the scores below me if penguin wins with
white he gets 10 points and he wins the whole
thing the winning score is going to be 10 points
at least what's going to happen here guys is white
going to win this is what it's all come down to
it's all come down to this last last game white
needs to win to take a thousand dollars but more
importantly the champion of internet chess the
title tuesday we have a kings indian defense i'm
i have to say i'm so impressed just by um
in general daniel naradicki's approach i
know he had that draw but his approach he's
taking lots of risks and playing the king's
gambit which is a really risky opening when you
maybe only need a draw to win it is like right
come on i don't mind let's remember if daniel
does draw looking at the scores he gets the 10
points and no one can catch him so black needs to
draw or win and this is this is really exciting
um now penguin playing queen d2 i don't know
if he's going to go completely crazy and start
pushing his h-pawn is he going to go h4 h5 no he's
playing it much more sensibly he's just going to
castle black i don't really like black's position
because these pawns seem a little bit weak
and you've got to look out for where there's
open lines and there's an open line here
and penguin has an idea of just attacking that
pawn later on on the other hand daniel's got to
play aggressively and he's done that and maybe
he's going to try to bring the bishop out here
and we can see that penguin is attacking
that's called a backwards pawn it's a pawn
that's on an open line where your opponent can
tack it so that's a porn weakness so white has
the better position but anything again can happen
here i don't like daniel's opening choice when
you need to draw you should probably go for a
more solid opening it's very risky playing this
crazy king's indian when you only need a draw
queen e7 played well is still in the balance
at the moment anything can happen um who do we
think is going to win i'm interested to see um
queen e7 and can white now play d5 this
is what he's thinking of with the idea of
attacking that one you can play d5 let's have
a look so you could go d5 placing that knight
under some pressure you can't take this one
because now bishop takes b6 wins a piece but
black can go c5 here i don't know if penguin
wants to do this he hasn't he's gone bishop f2
the idea of this one is to vacate that square for
one of his worst pieces and his worst piece here
is the knight on d1 the knight on d1 can
now move to that square this is typical
grand master maneuvering you look at your
worst pieces this knight which is clearly
a problem piece it gets in the way of the
rooks and you think okay where do i want
to put that knight and you try to think of a
better square so i think this is his idea i
mean another move he could have played was knight
to b2 and then bring the knight somewhere like c4
the problem daniel has he hasn't got much
activity here what can actually black do
you want to have pawn breaks in your position and
black doesn't have pawn breaks here if he goes a4
queen takes b4 just wins a pawn in the position uh
and oh no oh no his connection now let's remember
daniel is on an airplane oh no he's going through
turbulence daniel is playing this he might be the
first ever person to win title tuesday in 30 000
feet in the air or however high an airplane goes
but his connection's gone his connection's gone
no his connection's gone look you can see the
red thing his connection's gone get out turbulence
the plane the plane get your connection back plane
oh he's probably shaking there now
get the connection back this is oh no
this could be a horrible way this could be
a horrible way to the title tuesday's done
don't come on come on aeroplane come on aeroplane
i can see him now connection connect to wi-fi
aeroplanes wi-fi is terrible connect to wi-fi he
should have got a first-class seat because then
the connection would have been better it's going
to cost him dearly here can it connect you know
get on he's doing it 20 seconds can he get
the connect button 15 seconds connect connect
connect luggage is falling on his head someone's
drink goes straight in his face and he's still oh
no he's connected he's connected boom no he's
connected with six seconds left oh my words
oh oh but he's blundered a piece he panicked and
he's blundered a piece ah poor i have to say poor
old daniel that was so harsh he connected
with four seconds left but he made a move
he's wiping the drink off his face he's he's
you know he's got a suitcase on his head
and he's plays a move and it's a blunder oh no
and unfortunately oh no what happened there the
move he played was a blunder oh no and of course
he lost that one oh that is quite a sad end but
at least now he can ask the stewardess can i
have a napkin please i've got to get the drink
off my face and i'll have a large whiskey please
i'm also suing you for your internet connection
that cost me 750 you're going to see my lawyer
next week does he actually does he actually have
does he actually have a case to sue them does he
i don't know can he sue them maybe he can sue them
maybe he can sue the aeroplane for this for the
internet come on i want to see that in the news
anyway all out of all i have to say i have to
say congratulations to penguin and to be honest
penguin did absolutely nothing wrong and
if we go back to the position here where
all the drama happened penguin's a bit better in
this position he's got more pawns in the center
he's got the open c file and there's no reason
he should give daniel a draw it's not his fault
that daniel's on an airplane you know imagine
how strong daniel would be if he's actually
at a computer and not on an airplane i've
never you know that would be the first time
anyone's ever won title tuesday from in in the
air but it hasn't happened and daniel has now
dropped down congratulations to penguin is
it the first time that penguin has ever won
is it the first time that um everyone
daniel so unfortunate there we heard
that you're on an airplane you did so well
your connection went just at the wrong moment
oh we were cheering for you a bit there but of
course daniel sue the aeroplane sued the airplane
we now have daniel in the chat which is great um i
would sue the airplane for their dodgy connection
oh i'm sorry that's such a bad such a sorry
finish but i have to say congratulations to
penguin it might be the first time penguins ever
won title tuesday he's a very very talented player
and there's still a couple of games going
on there's four places that pay out and we
actually only have an nm which is lower than an
international master lower than a feed a master
and it's i think it's short for normalized master
nominal master as that's what it is nominal master
nm what could it be short for knobby master no
beast i i don't know i'm going to be rude here
if i keep going so oh hikaru hikaru's popped up
to third place okay i'm going to see if there's
any more games going on hikaru hikaru somehow
recovered to third place he's in third place now
and that's a really good recover from hikaru who
had some bad games earlier on the top four places
seem to to give prizes and we're just going to
look if there's any more games going on the games
are slowly ending now and we're going to have a
look at who's won the prizes daniel naradichi it
was bad turbulence did you get a drink in your
face daniel did you get a suitcase on your head
this is what we want to know i can just imagine
you on your phone literally jumping all over
trying to play the last round i can picture it
now just trying to try trying to use your finger
to get the connection button while you're while
you're all over okay you did get a bit of water
thrown all over you oh no daniel well look i have
to say you did amazingly well for coming second
considering you had turbulence over the
rocky mountains on a plane i mean i don't
know if anyone's done that before so um
congratulations on on that good result
that's really funny actually okay let's have
a look at the scores there's only a couple
more games going on uh penguin congratulations go
and check out penguin's twitch channel uh hikaru
has now overtaken daniel on tie break oh another
blow to daniel another blow ah no his last five
minutes has been horrible hikaru takes the silver
medal but well done to ikaru daniel in third place
and some other scores here i think anyone who
finishes i mean it's such a hard tournament
anyone in the top 20 is done very well
well i mean that's only because i dream
of coming in the top 20. and we'll have
a look down vidit 9 out of 11 good score
jabarva 9 out of 11 and niche there's some big
names there eric hanson was up there as well
so there we go oh that was intense that was
intense guys well i hope you enjoyed that um
for uh you know as much as you as much as
possible it was extremely exciting this week
and a bit dominated by american players so
well done to us of a who got really for i mean
penguin's got his flag up as oh well well done
to north korea that is just naughty isn't it
north korea come top uh i think penguins actually
from america so it's an american one two three
congratulations to to the guys at the top
really well done we got the winner in the chat
so congratulations to penguin well done penguin i
don't i don't know but they don't have they don't
have covid in north korea do they apparently so
maybe it's the safest place on the world to be
because there's no covid in north korea i'm
probably going to get assassinated by them now
now okay i'll stop there i'll stop there don't get
myself in trouble i have to keep reminding myself
these things don't get myself in trouble
don't do it simon be careful now um um yeah so
we can check out all these guys at the top all the
free people they all have their twitch channels
go and check them out go and subscribe
and follow them penguin hikaru daniel
if you want to look at my stuff it's ginger
gm twitch dot tv slash ginger gm and you
can check out my youtube channel as well which
is just ginger g if you just search ginger gm
you'll you'll you'll find me somewhere um so what
a brilliant event okay well i'm gonna now show
you a bit of a hype video and then we're gonna
wrap up the show have a great night everyone
enjoy yourselves a great day depending where you
are it's been a load of fun thank you very much
and stay tuned just to see the hype and get
some information on some great things coming up
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time this is the
magnus carlson squeeze um wow hicaro's
playing in front of hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now i mean
up by four games well i can resign yeah
carl knows it it started with 16 players
and it all came down to one man magnus
carlson and this is a pretty great matchup i know
people love hikaru nakamura hikaru is the favorite
for a reason he's the beast an absolute monster
it has been hecaro's speech his championship
this 2018 and car nakamura the overall 1c
takes it home in the species championship
obviously this is a rematch of last year's scc
final what a finish by the way i mean that's
been the story of the match the car nakamura
has just kind of out swindled out tricked and
out calculated wesley in the critical moment up
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking his head
ikaro wins upon he's going to draw
this game i can't believe it which
happened unbelievable carl nakamura holding that
position he had no business drawing that game
you